smoke in the skies of the capital
homes hospitals and businesses hit with
heavy artillery across several districts
in Tripoli
clashes erupted early Saturday between
rival armed groups
the fighting occurred in densely
populated areas and continued into the
night
the clashes have been have been ongoing
since last night they stopped for a bit
and then continued many of the victims
were Ordinary People
tired scared emotionally and physically
drained these people were trapped in
their homes for hours before they were
pulled out
City officials are calling for an end to
the violence
Civil Society institutions in Tripoli
strongly condemned the armed clashes in
the city and hold the participating
parties responsible for shedding
civilian blood intimidating security and
destroying private and public property
there are two governments who claim to
be in charge of the country one
recognized by the International
Community Based in Tripoli the other
drawing its power from the country's
East
says the only way forward is for
elections to be held
is the residence of Tripoli who are
paying the price they are the victims
the population of Tripoli is nearly 3
million people and they don't want
either government they want to vote for
who they want in power elections are the
only solution
things have calmed down since the
fighting began but people here still
fear that Libya may be on the verge of a
full-scale conflict now trainer Al
Jazeera